let's talk about shading
[Applause]
she was our colleague here at al jazeera
a palestinian-american journalist who
was shot dead by israeli forces while
doing her job according to journalists
who were there
huge crowds turned out for shadeen's
funeral
an event that ended up highlighting what
shirin had been reporting on her whole
career the way palestinians are
routinely treated under israel's
occupation
shireen's grave has now been sealed but
even after her death she continued to
tell the palestinian story so who was
shadeen abu akla what do we know about
how she was killed
and why is there so much anger about
what's happened since she died
was well known and well-loved
she'd been a tv correspondent for al
jazeera and palestine since 1997.
that's more than 20 years of shadiness
stories being broadcast into the living
rooms of millions of people across the
arab world she was born and raised
in jerusalem under occupation she was
telling the story that she was living
every day she was not just telling the
story of the people
she was telling the story the story of
her life as well and this is
what made her magically
an icon she was there in every town
every palestinian town village alleyway
refugee camp she wanted to do the
stories that nobody else wanted to do
and she
gave a voice to a lot of people who we
otherwise wouldn't have heard from
we we never assigned shireen to do a
story i mean she's just there
she shows up and that's what she did on
the last day of her life at 6 13 am
shadeen emailed the al jazeera office in
ramallah saying she was headed to the
janine refugee camp in the occupied west
bank to report on a raid by israeli
forces there was a response from the
newsroom saying that shireen we are
waiting for you to be live on the top of
the hour
suddenly right after that 20 minutes
after after this email um we heard the
news actually we we heard the news
circulating on social media that shireen
was killed
on the ground
[Music]
[Music]
had been shot in the head while wearing
a helmet and bulletproof vest clearly
marked with the word press
there's video of the moments after as
people tried to reach her and the
shooting continues
the journalists who were with shadeen
said the shots were fired by israeli
soldiers one of them was ali al-samudi
also from al jazeera he was shot in the
back
of
targeted by israeli forces
we considered this something intentional
because the bullet
hit exactly
the area under her ears where there is
no cover it was a targeted attack it was
a targeted assassination we consider it
that the israeli government immediately
sowed doubt over who fired the bullet
prime minister naftali bennett came out
with a statement saying it appears
likely that armed palestinians who were
firing indiscriminately at the time were
responsible and offered up a video of
palestinian gunmen in the area
but an al jazeera investigation examined
the location of that video and concluded
the gunshots fired in it were not
connected to shireen's death the israeli
rights group bet salem also examined the
video and came to the same conclusion
the investigative organization
bellingcat later published a more
detailed analysis using other publicly
available data they worked out that
shadine was here the israeli army was
here and that palestinian gunmen were
also in the area here
so that's a further distance it's a much
more obstructed line of sight to the
spot where where this tragic killing
took place bellancat's conclusion is
that the available video evidence does
not provide good grounds to doubt the
accounts of the journalists on the scene
indeed it appears to support them
although part of the frustration for
palestinians is the idea that the
eyewitness accounts given by palestinian
journalists aren't enough but there are
double standards at play the objectivity
of palestinian journalists is always
questioned
we never question the objectivity
of an american journalist or a canadian
journalist or let's say right now if
there were ukrainian journalist who were
killed who was killed in the exact same
way by a russian we wouldn't be rushing
to use the passive voice or calling it
clashes
or somehow not laying blame at the foot
of the russian government the israeli
government has now acknowledged that
shadine could have been killed by its
own forces and it's saying it's
investigating it's also suggested a
joint investigation with the
palestinians but they refused and said
any israeli involvement is just not
credible there are the criminals and the
criminals cannot investigate themselves
the experience very clearly demonstrates
that in the cases of such killings of
palestinians the announcement of
israel's desire or intention to
investigate does not lead to
accountability the investigation is an
old trick it's a strategy to
muddle waters to obfuscate
by time the palestinians have launched
their own investigation and say they
plan to take their evidence to the
international criminal court the u.n
security council has also called for an
immediate thorough transparent and
impartial investigation it was a rare
case of unanimity notably the council
statement does not call for an
international investigation it's really
quite vague
and leaves it up to the parties to
decide in this case it's making clear
that the security council wants to get
to the bottom of this but there's
disagreement among council members about
how to do that so it's really left to
the parties to work it out for
palestinians not only did they lose a
beloved journalist and member of their
community but on top of everything they
weren't allowed to mourn her in the way
they wanted
the same day shadeen was killed israeli
police entered her family home took down
a palestinian flag
and told mourners to turn off patriotic
music
they took down another flag outside a
church where shadeen's family was
receiving condolences
shadeen was a palestinian christian
so this is
and then there was what happened
at the funeral israeli police said there
was a plan made with shadeen's family to
drive the coffin from the hospital to
the church jadin's brother said there
was no agreement
after people started to carry the coffin
towards the hospital gates
this happened
[Applause]
israeli police beat them back and threw
stun grenades into the crowd
this is unbelievable
[Applause]
unbelievable
[Applause]
oh my god
such disrespect
for the dead and for those who are
mourning the dead
once the coffin was in the hearse police
continued trying to remove palestinian
flags
and at one point they smashed the back
window of the hearse to get to one this
level of violence is part and parcel of
the occupation the very nature of the
occupation it takes a lot of
abuse and violence to keep the
population of palestine without rights
and subjugate it now on the issue of
palestinian flags an israeli court
recently ruled that it's not a crime to
display one but there's also a law that
allows israeli police to remove them if
they judge that their display could
disturb the peace and police frequently
make that judgment they want to show us
that they are in control that people
cannot express their feelings they
cannot express their anger they cannot
carry a palestinian flag and they cannot
be said in the way that they want to be
sad so this is this is the regime
thousands of people crowded into
jerusalem's old city as shadeen's coffin
made its way to the cemetery
it turned out to be one of the biggest
gathering of palestinian mourners in
years
while all of this is hurtful and
shocking for so many palestinians it's
also unsurprising
palestinians see everything that's just
happened
as the latest injustice in a long
pattern of violence under israel's
occupation of palestinian land
an occupation that's illegal under
international law and enforces a system
of apartheid according to human rights
watch and amnesty international where
palestinians are treated like
second-class citizens and where
journalists are killed for trying to
share the palestinian struggle with the
world